well a woman's track and field star
named CC Telfer is currently dominating
of breaking records and all of that just
a really remarkable and impressive
athlete and I want to read you a little
bit of what the Daily wire article about
this about this really remarkable
remarkable individual Telfer is headed
to the NCAA championships on March 8th
through 9th reports a website for
Franklin Pierce athletics Telfer has
qualified in a pair of events as she
will compete in the 200 meter dash
and the 60 meter hurdles reads the site
noting that Telfer has the fastest time
of the year in the 200 meter dash which
is twenty four point oh eight seconds
which was set at the Northeast ten
conference championships earlier this
month
her fastest time in the 60 meter hurdles
is eight point three three seconds which
came in December at the UMass Boston
indoor open she is ranked third in the
country in the hurdles and seventh in
the 200-meter dash the 21 year old
cleaned up last Sunday at Smith College
taking home three Northeast Ten
Conference titles in scoring 31.5 of the
school's forty nine point five points
Franklin Pierce University finished
sixth which was the highest championship
finish in program history Telfer y then
it just goes out is just listing all of
these accomplishments Telfer was also
named women's most outstanding track
performer really impressive achievements
but there's one problem though it's a
problem that you have probably already
guessed which is that CC is actually a
dude named Craig this is a male a guy
hooray hooray stents other guys through
his entire scholastic career of running
but then in his senior year decided that
he was going to be a woman instead so he
switched teams literally and became a
woman and now he's cleaning up every
event that he competes in now this story
comes to us only a few days after Terry
Miller and Andrea Yearwood both males
came came first and second respectively
at the girls indoor track and field
championship in Connecticut they won
first and second in the 55 meter dash
these fellows also came in first and
second in the 100 meter dash last year
and Terry Miller won the 300 meter as
well this season so they're cleaning up
there as well just to give you an idea
of how utterly and completely insane
this is okay as if you needed to be told
but just to give you just to give you a
better idea Terry Miller again this is a
guy this is a dude he came in first
place with a thirty eight point nine in
the girls three hundred meter dash all
right that time thirty eight point nine
was enough to beat the entire field I
think I think second place in the
women's competition was like a second
behind him I think a second in a three
hundred meter dash is a very long time
but that time 38.9 it would not have
even placed him in the top 25 against
the men okay so he won the championship
in the woman women's field he would not
have even been in the top 25 in fact the
top man got a 35 point oh five in the
same event in Connecticut but just on
the men's side the top man got a 35
point point oh five number 25 got a
thirty six point seven five remember
Terry Miller one with a thirty eight
point nine meaning Miller was eight was
a full two seconds behind the 25th
ranked guy meaning he probably I don't
have the I couldn't I don't have the
entire ranking all I had was up to 25 he
probably wouldn't have even made it into
the top fifty he could maybe compete for
a top 100 at most a top 75 spot and yet
he dominates against women why is that
because of biology it's just that this
just shows you what kind of biological
advantage men have
and what what does this mean it means
that the girl who came in third in the
event where Terry Miller and and
Yearwood both competed the girl who came
in third was actually she actually won
she actually came in first place but she
was cheated out of the gold medal by
these two cheaters and the girl who came
in fifth and got no medal should have
come in third and gotten a bronze and
the girl who came in eighth place in the
event that the two dudes raced in should
have come in sixth and six is very
important because it puts you in front
of college coaches and Scouts and it
gives you a chance to compete it in
front of them which obviously was very
important in high school for the rest of
your of your track and field career and
by the way that that particularly young
young lady the one who came in eighth
but really came in sixth her name is
Selena Sewell and she appeared on Laura
Ingraham show a couple of nights ago and
I want to play for you a clip of this
just to show you just to show you kind
of the real human impact of this gender
madness that we've got going on so watch
this so I am very happy for these
athletes and I fully support them for
being true to themselves and having the
courage to do what they believe in but
in athletics it's an entirely different
situation it's scientifically proven
that males are built to be physically
stronger than females it's unfair to put
someone who is biologically a male who
has not undergone anything in terms of
hormone therapy against cisgender girls
how incredibly sad is that I mean how
sad is it first of all well it's sad
first of all that she was cheated out of
the out of that opportunity you know
that all of these girls are being
cheated but also if you if you watch
that interview you see how she feels the
need to keep saying how she's happy for
these two guys and the whole team
they're happy for them you know but of
course she's not really happy for the
guy nor
should she be there's no way this girl
or any of these girls are actually happy
for the dudes who came and stole the
medals from them you're not gonna be
happy for a cheater but she she's forced
to walk on eggshells to dance around it
and I don't blame her
she's in an impossible and unfair
situation these are just kids these are
kids we're even put in this situation
where it's just there's no way to win
for them and so they can either be
cheated and say nothing and lose that
way or they could speak up and
potentially face all kinds of
consequences if they do that again we
all know that of course she's not happy
for these cheaters she must be furious
as well she should be but she can't get
up there and say these two guys are
cheating and what they're doing is
despicable she can't say that even
though we all know that she's thinking
it and we're all thinking it because the
SJW Mob the leftist maniacs who put her
in this position they've also made her
feel afraid to say how she really feels
though she is we should we should
mention that she's all she is very brave
I think for saying as much as she does
and for speaking out at all and I
commend her for that because she's
braver than a lot of us she's braver
than a lot of adults and that's what I
keep thinking when I hear about these
stories where are the parents
now I'm sure that there are parents who
are protesting and speaking up but all
of the other parents should be just
should be saying something should be
protesting should be you you can't just
sit back and allow your daughters to be
cheated like this meanwhile Martina
Navratilova Navarrete Alejo he's messed
up Navratilova there we go was a legend
of women's tennis openly gay a gay
rights activist for a long time has been
expelled from a gay rights advocacy
group and is getting attacked by the
left because she wrote an article
recently stating the obvious that
and should not be able to compete
against women in tennis she says that
you know she's got all the respect to
the world for transgenders and she'll
use the pronoun that they want and all
that but there is a certain biological
reality to this and if you'll start
letting men into women's tennis it's
going to be the end of women's tennis
because women cannot compete with men in
tennis or in really any athletic
competition but she's being and for
saying that she is being silenced she's
being punished now here's the thing
about all this everybody knows that this
stuff is crazy right everyone knows that
it's crazy you right now watching this
whoever you are I don't know who you are
whatever your politics are whatever
planet you live on you know that it is
absolutely crazy that we are letting
biological males compete against women
and take their championships and their
trophies you know that we all know that
I don't care how far left you are you
still know that so just to sort of
highlight this point I did a poll on my
on my Twitter account last night and the
poll the poll question was very simple
do you think that biological males
should be allowed to compete against
women in women's sporting events yes or
no right and last I checked which is a
couple hours ago but last I checked
there had been 25 thousand answers to
this poll 25 thousand answers and of
those 25,000 97% were against allowing
boys to compete against girls
ninety-seven percent to 3 percent and
actually the 3 percent is even smaller
than that because I saw there quite a
few comments from people saying oh I I
hit yes I meant to hit no so it's
probably more like 98 2 or 99 1 but but
let's just say 97% for for argument's
sake yes it is a skewed poll this is not
a scientific poll I
I wouldn't claim that it is my followers
tend to be conservative so you know this
is not the kind of result that I can
send to a scientific journal or
something like that it is skewed but I
mean come on you could not find this
kind of consensus on any other issue I
guarantee you that even with my
conservative skewing Twitter followers
if I put out a poll about abortion or
gay marriage or gun rights or
immigration or taxes or it literally
anything else you are not gonna find 97
percent of people who agree I mean it's
very difficult to find 25 to find a
group of 25 thousand people where almost
where almost all of them agree on not
just an issue but on a supposedly
contentious controversial issue right
this is I mean this is all anecdotal of
course but you could also go go look at
the comments section under any news
story about these kinds of things about
boys competing against girls and you
look at the comment section every cut
doesn't matter where yard whatever site
you go to almost every single comment is
going to be opposed not just to opposed
but extremely angrily opposed and that
but or just go talk to people in the
real world next time you're sitting
around a dinner table with 10 or 11
people bring up this discussion every
single person is going to say this is
crazy we can't be doing this again you I
cannot think of any other issue where
almost everyone you come across will
agree now I was actually curious so I
googled to see if I could find an
article written by someone who will
actually defend the idea of having
biological boys compete against girls
and by the way I don't want to get
sidetracked here but I just want to I
want to remark on the insanity of the
fact that we even have to use the phrase
biological boy or
biological mail it's like saying
geometric circle right it it's it's it's
totally redundant and the fact that we
have to use that phrase it all just
shows how confused everything is there's
yea biological mail there is no other
kind of mail it's of course it's
biological but anyway I wanted to find
an article defending this whole this
whole thing you would think considering
we see this happening across the country
with boys being allowed to compete
against girls I mean there must be
people who agree with hits there must be
some kind of argument in favor of it
considering the fact that it's happening
everywhere and I was legitimate
legitimately curious what a person could
possibly say what kind of argument could
you possibly string together to support
this madness but as I was looking on
Google I had a really hard time finding
a defense of it anywhere this isn't the
kind of although you have although the
left
generally speaking seems to support this
rarely will you find any individual
leftist who will who will speak up and
actually offer a defense of it and I had
trouble finding it I did eventually find
something at a publication called the
nation relatively well known and it's
about the narrative lova thing written
by someone who thinks that she's a trans
phobe and she's wrong for wanting to
exclude men from women's sports here is
the article here's the argument that
this article makes I'm gonna read read
from it
it says the reality I can't even keep a
straight face it starts with the reality
the reality is that there is no
scientific data showing that trans women
are more likely to be successful in
women's sports there is no scientific
data showing that men are more
successful in sports there's also zero
evidence that there's a push by trans
women to take over the women's sports
world the denial of their right to take
part in sports only leads to further
marginalization and oppression
the fear that they are somehow
encroaching on women athletes is
actually a definition of transphobia so
you see how there's no argument here
they this person just immediately
transitions to the emotional appeal of
well it's oppression it makes
transgender people feel bad about
themselves
it's transphobia immediately pivots to
emotions labels and all of that the most
that they can do is very briefly deny
reality by saying there's no scientific
data that's the argument the argument is
is it's not an argument at all it's just
the argument is to look at reality and
say no that's not real the argument is
looking at a at a solid wall like I'm
looking at that wall right there and
saying nope there's no wall there it's
not there that's my argument I believe
that there's no wall there I mean no
sign no scientific there is no
scientific data that men have an
advantage over women in sports they're
not even trying they're not even trying
to come up with a with a even halfway
convincing argument they may as well say
that there's no scientific data proving
that a person in water is more likely to
drown than a person on dry land it's a
total non sequitur but if I really have
to get into this here's some scientific
data a man's leg is 80 percent muscle a
woman's leg is 60 percent muscle men
have larger fast-twitch muscle fibers
men have less body fat men have 20 times
more testosterone do you know what that
is natural steroids men are on steroids
naturally they have 20 times more of
that steroid in their body and I'm not
done men have larger hearts men have
larger lungs they have longer legs they
have smaller hips they are literally
literally built to be faster and
stronger they have dozens dozens of
biological advantages if not more if not
hundreds of biological advantages women
literally have no chance none if they
have to compete against me
if for instance the floodgates were
opened and women's let's say the women's
NCAA basketball league was were to be
fully integrated well no woman would
ever see the court ever again it's the
end of women's sports it here's the
here's the real reality the worst man in
the NBA is going to be considerably
better than the best woman in the WNBA
just a fact that is how vast is the
chasm between men and women when it
comes to to athletics and again this is
biological that's all it is a biological
reality I mean there's nothing we could
do about the fact that men literally
their legs are made of more muscle and
they have bigger hearts and bigger lungs
and and all of that longer legs I mean
it's just you could be a you could wish
that wasn't the case you could you can
be opposed to it all you want you could
write it on a sign saying no more men
with more muscle in their legs I mean
you can do what you want but it still is
going to remain the reality and everyone
knows this that's the thing that's the
pointers everybody knows I I doubt that
there is any even halfway sane person in
the country who actually thinks that
it's fair and reasonable to have men
competing against women there are some
people who will pretend they think it's
okay but I don't even believe them
because just like what I just read when
you listen to their argument they have
no argument at all
so there's simply no way they're
convinced by what they're saying they
think they have to have this
opinion but why is it why is the tiniest
fringed minority a group of people
making an argument so insane
so baseless so lacking in common sense
that it literally cannot be defended why
is this group allowed to impose itself
on us if almost all of us agree that
this is crazy
and we and if almost all of us can
recognize the basic biological
advantages that men have first of all
the basic biological difference between
men and women and the the advantage is
that those differences bestow on men in
the field of athletics if we almost all
of us can recognize that then why is it
that this stuff is happening well I
asked that question kind of in passing a
few days ago on the show I didn't really
answer it so here's the answer the
answer is that this very small fringe
minority and this is when I talk about
the fringe minority I'm talking about
mostly about people who pretend that to
think that this is okay because as I
said I don't I'm not sure there's anyone
who really thinks it's okay
and that minority even though they are
minority they happen to control all of
the major institutions they happen to
control academia the media Hollywood and
they're in control of an entire
political party one of the two major
parties a democrat party so that's how
that's how they've done it that's how
this really fringe radical wacko idea
has somehow invaded our culture and sort
of set up camp
but but but but here's the here's the
really sad thing it's it's that even
though you have these institutions that
are pushing this idea and those
institutions are very powerful and
they're run by powerful people the fact
still remains that if all of us who
disagree if we were really vocal about
it and really opposed and we actually
stood up and said no well this stuff
would be happening whenever in any case
when you've got you know in any state or
in any school district when they start
doing this if all of the people who
think it's crazy actually stood up and
said no absolutely not this is crazy we
will not tolerate it and if the parents
started saying if you do that I'm
pulling my my my daughter out of the
sport you bring boys in we're the sports
gonna be over that's what's gonna happen
if everyone said that if everyone did
that then this stuff wouldn't be
happening so yes it's a small minority
in the major powerful institutions that
are imposing this on us but we are
allowing it to be imposed on us we are
just lying down and saying okay so I got
gee I really think that this is kind of
nuts guys but all right I don't want to
I don't want to be labeled a trans phobe
look you got to get to a point where
those kind of labels Malaybalay
means nothing to me I don't care about
that label I am not offended by it I
don't care it is the stupidest label it
has no meaning whatsoever yeah I'm a
Transpo because I think men are men and
women are women fine go ahead I don't I
really don't care it means no W you got
to get to a point where that label just
does not bother you at all it means
nothing I don't care
you can shout it and you could cry all
you want it does not matter to me and I
think we all need to get to that point
where when people start shouting it
that's transphobia you know what you do
you
laughs at that you laugh at it treat it
with contempt and that's the other
problems that I think there are people
who think well-meaning people but they
think that yeah you know we yea I'm
opposed to it but we got to be delicate
and careful and you know we have any
diplomatic about i wouldnt want to hurt
people's fence now we're past that now
we're past that the greater could say
look the the concern is the girl that
clip i played for you the girl who's
these girls that are being cheated it's
their feelings that we should be
concerned about those two dudes who'd i
have no concern for their feelings at
all none i don't care and i know you
might say well that's that's that's
cruel that's that's not right i don't
care about their feelings they are
cheaters and you know the other thing
they know what they're doing now they
might have mental problems that they
think that they're girls when they're
not so so maybe they maybe they do maybe
they don't and they're just straight-up
cheating they realize that they they
realize they can't hack it against the
boys so they're doing this it's just
total self-interest that could be the
case maybe they do have some some real
mental issues but that doesn't let them
off the hook morally they know what
they're doing
they know that they as soon as I step on
the on the on the track they have
removed any chance that any of these
girls have to succeed and they know that
and they are being totally selfish and
so what I should care about their
feelings as they act selfishly and they
cheat I don't all right let's see moving
on this was funny
usually I save my emails for the end of
the show but I wanted to share two
emails with you right now these are both
in reaction to my show yesterday so let
me read the first well the first one
says Matt what has happened to you you
you you've become a shameless trumpet
booster I never thought you would sell
your soul to the Trump cult but that is
what has happened you should be ashamed
of yourself I've unfollowed you on all
platforms I know you won't care but I
thought I'd tell you anyway
okay that was the first email second one
dear Matt your never Trump Bowl s is too
much to stomach you can't seem to ever
give the president a break he's trying
to fix this country all you do is
criticize him sorry but I'm done with
you so that's just funny because that's
in reaction to the same show it appears
that I am a never Trump Trump boosting
Trump hating Trump loving Trump cultist
with Trump derangement syndrome that's
it's a very complex condition that I
have I'm used to these kinds of emails
of course I've been getting them for
three years usually though it fluctuates
day to day or week to week depending on
what's in the news it was funny to get
to get to two versions the two competing
versions in the same day and that was
because yesterday on my show I offered a
defense of Trump in regards to the Cohen
hearings and I said that the hearings
only help to vindicate Trump from any
claims that he engaged in any kind of
criminal behavior so I said that but
then I also I criticized Trump for his
performance in North Korea especially
when he lied for Kim jong-eun and
provided cover for him when he Trump was
asked about North Korea torturing an
American citizen to death and Trump
claimed that Kim jong-un didn't know
that that was happening and and he would
he was really upset about it which is
just untrue of course and it is a lie
and it is alive for the sake of a
murderous dictator so I criticize Trump
for that as any rational person would
and should I defended Trump on the Kohen
hearings because it's clear to me that
Cohen has nothing on Trump and moreover
I'm very disturbed by what the Democrats
are doing here the precedent they're
setting by refusing to accept the
results of a free and fair election and
instead doing everything they can
throwing anything they can against the
wall to try to get rid of the president
I find that to be a very dangerous
precedent so I defended the president
over that how is it that I could draw a
trump favorable conclusion on one issue
but then a trump negative conclusion on
the other well because for me I don't
judge things
based on the fact of Trump being
involved that for me is not the is not
what everything hinges on i assess what
i think the actual truth of the matter
is and then I draw my conclusions from
there if Trump is on the wrong side of
that line then I criticize him if he's
on the right side of it then I defend
him you know someone actually told me
recently that this approach is a cop-out
and this was a Trump fan saying this and
he felt basically that my moral
obligation is to bow at the altar of
Trump and to support everything he does
no matter what because Trump is Lord God
and Savior I've also heard a similar
thing in Reverse from liberals saying
that it's a cop-out to support Trump
when he does good things because Trump
is bezel bub Trump is Satan Trump is is
Lucifer I find both of these attitudes
not just wrong but ridiculous and not
just ridiculous but embarrassing and not
just embarrassing but an American and
not just an American but morally and
intellectually reprehensible it doesn't
make any sense to me whatsoever
and I I don't understand why so many
people struggle with this you don't you
don't need to have one line about Donald
Trump I think here's the point if you
find that you always criticize Trump no
matter what he does that's a good hint
that you aren't using your brain and if
you find that you always defend Trump no
matter what he does that is also a good
hint that you aren't using your brain
and in conclusion I would say let's all
use our brains instead but how about
that let's just use our brains and look
at any particular situation and assess
it on the merits
that's what we're supposing there
supposed to do in that as Americans we
are supposed to be always skeptical and
critical of our leaders to be a fan to
be a fan of a politician there in my
opinion there is no place for that in
America you should never have if you
find yourself grabbing the pom-poms and
becoming a cheerleader for a politician
that is a that's a bad sign that's that
is not what our founders had in mind
that's what they do over with you know
in dictatorships and monarchies and all
about that we escaped that system and in
our system a politician is supposed to
be a public servant that's supposed to
be serving us and so we are in a
position where we can look at them and
say no I don't I don't agree with how
you are serving us and I'm going to tell
you but there's an equal and opposite
approach which is as I said to to look
at a politician because they're in the
wrong party or for whatever reason and
to see them as evil incarnate and to
only be critical of them and I think
that also is is very is very silly way
of going about it all right let me get
to some of your emails before we wrap up
today Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh Oh gmail.com is the email address
this is from Ronald he says hi Matt big
fan of the show do you think the
government should be involved in
protecting marriage ben shapiro says no
because the government has done a bad
job i personally do not buy that
argument we rightly let the government
protect life and private property
despite the government's frequently poor
record marriage like life and property
is foundational to society shouldn't the
government therefore protect marriage as
well
well ronald i wouldn't phrase it that
way i think that this protect marriage
thing is kind of a false premise the
government does not need to protect
marriage the government rather should
recognize marriage recognize it for what
it actually is by definition for what it
necessary
we must be which is a union between a
man and a woman and as you say the
foundation for for for human
civilization and a foundation for the
family when I say recognized I mean just
that recognize recognize what marriage
is legally and the government doesn't
need to do much more than that that was
my argument the whole time before before
the Supreme Court decision now it's sort
of a moot point but before that point
what I was saying is first of all we're
not looking to make gay marriage illegal
that's not the point
we're not looking to turn the government
into some sort of theocratic defender of
biblical marriage this isn't about
biblical marriage at all in fact this is
just about marriage marriage is a
certain thing it performs a certain
function it has a certain purpose and if
you get rid of that purpose and that
function then it's then marriage is
nothing it doesn't mean anything anymore
there's no reason for it it serves no
purpose
so if marriage is going to be anything
and if it's going to have any purpose
whatsoever then it must be a union
between a man and a woman if you take
that away the marriage is why well
people say oh it's people that love each
other it's a union between people that
love each other well that's you can you
can get together who with whoever you
want and love them it's not it's not a
issue for public concern we don't need
the government we don't we don't need
the government involved in that at all
you don't need a you don't need a label
for that you don't need a ceremony you
don't need anything if you want to if
you want to love somebody you don't you
don't need anything for that you just
love them right the whole idea of
marriage the reason why we have the
documentation and the ceremony and all
of the stuff surrounding it is that it's
not just about love in fact in fact I
mean sometimes in a marriage people will
go through a tough period where well
they still love each other because love
is an act of choice but they may even go
through periods where they have very
little affection for each other
yet they're still married because
marriage is more than that
marriage is about being the foundation
for the family and so I think our
argument as defenders of this was or
should have been that we just want the
government to recognize that this is
what marriage is all right so you know
it's kind of splitting hairs a little
bit but I think it's an important point
this is from Jesse says hi Matt it's
interesting to me that you talked about
ectopic pregnancy today because just
yesterday my wife and I had a
conversation about that very subject we
are both pro-life but agree that in
cases like ectopic pregnancy abortion
may be regrettably necessary but suppose
they come up with a procedure where they
can relocate an ectopic pregnancy to the
uterus so the pregnancy can go to term
healthily should we require women to get
that surgery rather than an abortion for
the purpose of this thought experiment
let's say that the abortion is a simple
drug and the procedures and open surgery
with the attendant risks that go along
with that it's an interesting
hypothetical first of all just against
speaking of splitting hairs as I won't
get into the whole thing again but as I
explained yesterday when a woman is is
taking care of an ectopic pregnancy so
that you know she doesn't have a burst
fallopian tube burst and bleed to death
I don't think I don't I would call that
abortion that's sort of talk about the
principle double effect and everything I
would say that that is not that is not
an abortion although although it has a
although it has the same result because
the intention is entirely different
whereas an abortion in an abortion you
are just directly killing a child
because you don't want the child that's
that's that's what an abortion is it's
not the case for that type of privacy
although I know what you're saying
as to yes to your hypothetical I would
say that's an interesting hypothetical I
would say that yes if that technology
existed then I suppose a couple that
found themselves in a situation with an
ectopic pregnancy I think they would
have a moral obligation to get that
procedure the whole point with an
ectopic pregnancy as it stands now is
that there is no way to save the
pregnancy there's nothing you can do
and if you do nothing then the woman
could die so that's the whole reason why
it becomes relatively clear-cut case but
if you could save the pregnancy then I
think you would have a more obligation
to do that see a lot of emails about the
ectopic pregnancies discussion they were
all very interesting but running out of
time so I can't read all of them let's
see I'll read this is from father Greg
he says I'm a longtime listener of your
podcast and while I don't always agree
with you you can at least see the
internal logic of your position when I
disagree in your discussion of the
principle of double effect you missed
one essential element the positive or
desired effect cannot flow from the
negative effect that is why you missed
the moral distinction between the
removal of the fallopian tube and the
direct abortion in the case of the
removal of the fallopian tube you remove
the tube and the child dies due to a
lack of ability to sustain its life the
positive effect the mother's health
outcome flows from the tubule removal
and the secondary effect the death of
the child remains morally distinct even
though it is foreseen whereas in the
case of the direct abortion the positive
outcome directly flows from the death of
the child the mother's health is
maintained because the child is killed
it is not the case that you do not
intend to kill the child in this
instance it may be the case that you
only intend to kill the child because
you do not see another reasonable option
and therefore do reluctantly however the
intended purpose of abortion remains the
same the key principle of the effects
remaining morally distinct is what
distinguishes the principle of double
effect for the simple logic of the ends
justifying the means I understand the
distinction of your arguments I would
only counter that the reason why you say
it's morally acceptable to remove the
fallopian tube is the intention correct
me if I'm wrong what you're saying is
the intention is to remove a block the
intention the act and the intention is
let's remove this blocked fallopian tube
right the fact that it is blocked with a
pregnancy is a very tragic but secondary
fact well I would say that the point of
the drug is the same the drug is only
without the medically unnecessary
surgery so
the point of the drug is to clear out a
blocked fallopian tube for the sake of
protecting the mother's life and
preventing a rupture that would kill her
and it happens tragically that there is
a life that a life is part of what is
blocking the fallopian tube but that is
not the direct intention the direct
intention again is to clear out this
tube that if you don't it will rupture
so that I think you could argue that the
sort of the ending of the pregnancy is a
is a secondary fact so it seems to me
that that taking the drug is as much of
a direct attack on life as removing the
tube I could be wrong but that's just
that's just how it seems to me finally
this is from Jerry
it says Matt I shouldn't be answering
this but Matt what is the most
frustrating thing about women in your
experience what's the most frustrating
thing about women and your experience
yeah this is a trap I should but I will
fall for it I'll tell you I'll tell you
what is I tell you what in my wife's
case I'll tell you what the most
frustrating thing about her is I don't
know if this is true for every woman but
I suspect it probably is and here's a
problem my wife has an amazing memory
she remembers everything everything she
there's I don't think she's ever
forgotten anything in her life she
remembers every detail from the moment
of her conception okay she remembers
everything that's ever happened to her
and on the other hand I forget
everything now if you were to ask her
what is the most frustrating thing about
me she would have a really difficult
time deciding but I think one of the
things she would mention is that I
forget everything I have a bad memory so
I am citing this as more of a defense
mechanism what I'm saying is no no the
problem isn't that I forget everything
the problem is that you remember you see
if we both just forgot everything all
the time
then it would be like momento and and
every single day is a new adventure be
like Groundhog's Day every day is a new
adventure you know so so it would it
would solve a lot of problems the
problem with her memory is twofold one
it's hard for me to win arguments
because you know she's so just as an
example a few days ago my wife was
having back problems and she kept
mentioning this part of her back that
was causing her problems with hurting
her and she was telling me specifically
like it's it's right here in this area
and she was she was showing me well at
night she mentioned it again that her
back was hurting and so I said I said oh
where does it hurt you on your back and
she said are you kidding I've been I've
been telling you all day and then I said
okay but I mean come on you know I had
back problems all the time and it sound
like you remember exactly where on my
back it hurts and then she said yeah
it's right below your left shoulder
blade and I said okay you know let's
just forget that point let's just move
on from that because apparently you do
remember so and that kind of thing that
kind of thing happens all the time the
other problem with her memory is that
she's able to hear she's able to hear a
very long and drawn-out story from
somebody and retain all of the
information that they tell her and
she'll and she has like this little
magical elf in her brain that just
transcribes everything anyone tells her
and then files it away in a filing
cabinet I don't have that elf and it's
not my fault I don't have the magic
globe I don't know where she got it I
don't know if she was born with it I
don't have it and that's not my fault
so when she wants to relay information
to me she will she forgets something
this is the one thing she does forget
she forgets that I don't have the elf so
she'll she'll tell me information in the
form of this long story and she'll
expect me to remember at the very least
the important bits of it so if she has
something important to tell me she'll
eventually get to the important part but
she has to set it up set the stage
introduce all the major characters the
minor characters sometimes she'll go
back she'll do it you know
she'll kind of do a review of the last
episode you know last time on and she'll
do that and then she set this give me
describe the setting and everything
sometimes she begins with this lengthy
preamble sometimes sometimes would be a
story for her will begin like the
beginning of 2001 a Space Odyssey
where it'll begin with like the Big Bang
and the dinosaurs and she'll slowly make
her way
weaving everything together and then
she'll make her way to the incident she
wants to describe to me and she's a
brilliant storyteller but by the time
she gets to the important part I'm a
million miles away in my head I it's
been information overload and I'm
overwhelmed and then I get in trouble
three hours later when I ask her
something that she already covered in
the story she told me and she'll go
really I just told you that
and then I'll say yeah but I got lost
around the time when you were you know
talking about the French Revolution I
got lost somewhere around there I didn't
make it too modern to modern times so
this is why I asked my wife and and all
women I think could do this as well any
story that you tell a man begin with the
major bullet points begin like a you
know like the reports you used to do in
high school in grade school begin like
that where it's like in this report I am
going to tell you ABC so you start with
that and then I can lock that away in my
brain it's like okay I got that ABC
right boom got it it's in there and then
you can get into the whole story and the
whole the whole long essay and the you
know the chapter book and all of that
and I'll pick up bits and pieces of that
but I got the main parts here and I
won't forget them but you got a start so
I literally have to tell my wife
sometimes before she begins the story to
say okay well so give me the bullet
points first and then she'll give me the
bullet points and then she'll tell the
story and I found that that that that
works so you know I think maybe that's
something all women could think about
doing there is my my answer you thought
I wouldn't answer that question but I
did all right and if my wife ever
to this segment of the show she will
remember she'll remember it that I know
I'll leave it there hope you guys have a
great weekend Godspeed